[Music]
who
am i
what do you want to do your life frankie
i don't know all right what kind of
stuff you want to make
i think you got potential i want to make
your next picture really yeah
what now yeah right now yo what's up
thanks for checking out this video my
little niece worships these guys who do
and say nothing
yo why is my existence so lit and
promote a lifestyle of doing and saying
nothing
hashtag swimming pool that's that
cocktail i just think this pineapple
life
you can't be following me like i'm no
one special man
holy you've got talent you want to be
the guys that made two cool videos but
you want to be
no one special this is the beginning
people came oh my god
it's crazy how good this is huh
we have phone or no phone i'm charles
melton and i'm here with no one special
then we have a game show that idea
good idea i love you know what's special
this is just feeling so right
we're about to go stratospheric you know
i see you
right you see don't hurt her i love that
jake
[Music]
are you prepared to let the world see
the real you
he's not who he says he is your success
directly contradicts your message
doesn't it you tell viewers
they're stupid for watching us i want
you to wake up because you're getting
swept up
you're so jealous of him get the viewers
back up before we lose
prophet will not be accepted in his
hometown you get to lead the revolution
you can stop
it
have you told me one single thing that
was true
hey myself
[Music]
i'm no one special cut
that was great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you